[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir une part importante de ce
journal va être consacrée au premier
bilan de la visite en Chine du président
de la République à l'heure qu'il est le
président Pompidou se trouve à Tatung à
300 km de Pékin où il visitera demain
des grottes AB abritant d'antique
sculpture bouddique monsieur Pompidou
est accompagné dans son voyage par
Monsieur schwenla et qui est relevé par
les observateurs et les journalistes car
il est exceptionnel que le Premier
ministre chinois se déplace en province
en compagnie de visiteurs étrangers
avant de quitter Pékin le président
Pompidou a tenu une conférence de presse
et il est ainsi le premier chef d'État
étranger à se livrer au jeu des
questions et des réponses en territoire
chinois monsieur Pompidou a notamment
annoncé qu'il tiendrait d'une conférence
de presse à Paris le 27 septembre
prochain et il s'est attaché à faire un
premier bilan de son séjour en Chine
le président Pompidou et monsieur chuenl
ne se quittent plus ils se sont vu
longuement cet après-midi et ce soir
monsieur chuenl et l'invité de Monsieur
Pompidou en terre française c'est-à-dire
à l'ambassade de France où il n'était
pas venu depuis le 14 juillet
1971 à la fin du dîner monsieur Pompidou
prend le train pour Tatung et pendant 3
jours à hangcho à shanghï il va regarder
vivre la Chine il a il est vrai pour
compagnon de voyage le meilleur des
guides monsieur l' en personne ce sera
donc du tourisme politique et nous
pouvons encore avoir des surprises avant
que monsieur Pompidou ne quitte le sol
chinois en fin d'après-midi premier
rencontre du président Pompidou avec la
presse française et chinoise depuis le
début de ce voyage le cadre une des 100
salles du palais de l'Assemblée du
peuple mais pas n'importe quelle salle
celle dédiée à la province du unan où
est né le président Mao c'est la
première fois qu'un chef d'État étranger
donne une conférence de presse dans ce
temps de la Chine moderne dès
maintenant je voudrais
indiquer
que les analyses que nous
faisons de la situation
mondiale ne sont pas
identiques ni nos situations
géographiques ni nos
dimension
ni nos situations
économique ne le
permettrait mais elles sont sur bien des
points
convergantes en
particulier nous sommes les uns et les
autres
convaincus que
jamais le monde n'a été dans une période
aussi fertile en changement
en mutation comme nous disions
maintenant en
France et que par
conséquent il est nécessaire à
chacun à la
fois de
s'assurer de
lui-même et de sa solidité et de sa
stabilité mais en même temps de se
prêter à l'évolution et de ne pas
prêtendre
la contrarié il ne sert de rien de la
contrarié on gagne quelques
délai mais le fond c'est que il faut
vivre avec son temps suivant une formule
banale et il faut tâcher de
l'accompagner nous sommes également
d'accord sur je crois là aussi avec des
nuances chacun voit plus ou moins aspect
des choses sur le
fait que dans ces périodes de
changement certains
périls continuent comme toujours dans le
passé de peser sur le monde et sur
l'humanité et qu'il faut le
savoir et il en viendra
d'autres mais que notre action et
notamment notre action en matière de
défense a pour but
d'abord de préserver notre indépendance
et ensuite de
servir la paix à laquelle les peuples
aspirent sans qu'il soit bien
entendu bon pour eux de s'abandonner à
des illusions nous sommes très contents
de constater qu'il existe entre la Chine
et la France de bonnes relation
et maintenant monsieur le Président vous
êtes venu effectuer une visite
officielle en Chine et avez fait l'objet
d'un accueil chaleureux je voudrais
monsieur le Président vous poser une
question que voici comment voyez-vous
les perspectives du développement des
rapports entre la Chine et la France
merci je les vois d'abord
monsieur comme il est naturel dans le
domaine politique car c'est finalement
ce qui commande
tout et c'est pourquoi j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure des échanges de vues que nous
avons eu et également du contact que
nous compons maintenir entre nous mais
je pense
aussi
que ces échanges politiques doivent se
préciser et se traduire dans la
pratique on parle beaucoup de commerce
et d'économie et c'est capital bien sûr
président même ordre d'idée est-ce que
sur deux points particuliers le Concorde
et le SAM vous avez l'impression que nos
interlocuteurs pourrait aller vers une
concrétisation de ces échanges dont vous
félicitez vous n'avez pas choisi les
deux sujets sur lesquels nousous sommes
le plus étendus il y en a un la
télévision en couleur qui de toute
manière me paraît un objectif encore
éloigné dans le
temps quant à l'affaire Concorde et bien
vous savez où l'on en est
euh cela soulève des problèmes mais
euh je suis loin de désespérer
disons pour parler comme les
Britanniques un peu en dessous enfin il
y a des domaines très importants où déjà
des accords sont signés sur le point de
lettre et d'autres iront se développant
j'en suis convaincu je vais pas vous
faire le détail n'étant pas en mesure de
le faire et n'étant pas non plus
voyageur de commerce et ce n'est pas un
terme péjoratif dans ma bouche enfin
c'est un fait jacques Olivier chattard
24h sur La Une monsieur président est-ce
que les décisions prises à Copenhague
ont été bien accueillies par vos
interlocuteurs
chinois Copenhague est loin de la
Chine mais naturellement j'ai été en
contact direct avec Monsieur le Ministre
Affaires étrangères également d'ailleurs
en contact permanent avec le Premier
ministre
français et j'ai constaté que les
dirigeants chinois de leur côté
s'intéressaient à ce qui s'était fait à
Copenhague ce n'est pas un mystère que
de dire
que les efforts qui sont faits pour
affirmer l'identité européenne pour
développer l'unité
européenne sont vu d'un bon œil à
péquin j'ai constaté
d'ailleurs avec un
que les dirigeants chinois sur ce point
étaient moins soupçonneux vis-à-vis de
la politique
française que ne le sont quelquefois les
porte-paroles de la presse
française je n'ai pas étudié encore en
détail les décisions de Copenhague
encore que elles é été longuement
préparé vous vous en doutez mais il me
semble que c'est un progrès ver ce qu'on
appelle l'identité européenne d'un terme
qu' me semble nous avons
inventé et qu'en tout
cas nous comptons bien soutenir et
appuyer et par
conséquent nous nous en félicitons et
nous nous félicitons que d'autres s'en
félicitent Jean-Pierre elcaba chnf2
monsieur le Président quelle conséquence
votre voyage peut-il avoir à votre avis
sur les rapports de la France avec
l'Union S
tique quelle conséquence
voulez-vous que ce voyage est il n'est
pas de notre part absolument dirigé
contre personne pas plus contre l'Union
soviétique contre un autre nous sommes
dans un système politique qui fait que
la France veut être bien avec tout le
monde nous savons que ça n'est pas
toujours facile
nous savons que ça n'est pas forcément
éternel que le monde évolue mais nous
continuons à considérer que la politique
de détente et d'entente que nous
poursuivons en Europe est la bonne pour
nous français et pour les pays d'Europe
occidentale cela
dit une fois de plus pour la 10e fois je
crois je
rappellerai la formule du chancelier
brand n-ce
pas détente plus défense égal
sécurité nous ne séparons
pas la politique de détente et d'entente
d'une politique de défense nationale en
attendant le jour où cette défense
pourra être européenne ce qui n'est pas
pour
l'immédiat monsieur Président je me fais
pas beaucoup d'illusion sur votre
réponse mais je pose tout de même la
question comment ouler votre entretien
avec le président
Maou et bien j'étais assis à sa
gauche et dans des fauteuils très
confortables nous avons parlé beaucoup
et de
tout même de
poésie même
d'histoire et aussi de
politique
et c'est cet échange de
vue était
évidemment très
important il était aussi pour moi
euh plus qu'important dans la mesure je
le répète où je me trouvais en présence
d'un homme d'une stature
exceptionnelle et
où la
sagesse des
années
s'ajoute à la vivacité de
l'intelligence
mais après ça nous avons regardé un peu
le bureau les
idéogrammes nous avons parlé avec
beaucoup de sympathie et
d'amitié sur le reste vous n faisiez pas
d'illusion vous aviez bien
raison
monie président Pierre saintrichin
sud-ouest monsieur le Président
qu'est-ce qui jusqu'à présent vous a le
plus étonné en
Chine ce qui m'a frappé
[Musique]
c'est car je n'étais pas ici pour faire
du tourisme je ne cessa de le
répéter ce qui m'a frappé c'est la
connaissance extraordinaire que j'ai
rencontré chez les dirigeants chinois et
en particulier chez Monsieur sch de tous
les problèmes du monde et quelquefois
des plus éloignés et même des plus
petits et bien que
j'ai la prétention de suivre les
questions d'assez près et bien j'en ai
tiré encore une leçon
supplémentaire
Monsieur R Felden les Dernières
Nouvelles d'Alsace à la lumière de vos
impressions de voyage pensez-vous
monsieur le Président que l'expérience
de la nouvelle société chinoise puisse
influer sur l'évolution de la société
française nous sommes loin les uns des
autres et par conséquent quels que soit
les rapports qui
s'établissent les
influences ne peuvent être que pe
partielle et lente enfin nous avons
constaté déjà je l'ai dit au Premier
ministre schwenlik par exemple dans le
domaine du
costume la France a été influencée et
que le costume d'Ao a été très à la mode
et bien il y a certainement des choses à
prendre pour nous dans les perspectives
qui sont celles de la société chinoise
sur le plan même
social veut pas dire pour autant que
nous ayons les mêmes convictions ni le
même
régime
mais il y a quelque chose
qui
facilite la
compréhension et
aussi ce type
d'influence c'est
que encore que la Chine soit sur la voie
du développement
industriel encore que j'ai moi-même
donné du développement
industriel une priorité pour l'effort
français donner au développement
français à la base nous sommes des
peuples paysans cela traduit un certain
état
d'esprit une certaine
placidité pas toujours
parisienne une certaine
patience pas toujours parisienne mais
fondamentalement française et
fondamentalement
chinoise je crois mesdames et
messieurs avoir répondu à toutes vos
questions je voudrais pour
terminer dire combien nous avons été
tous et moi
d'abord touchés par
l'accueil extrêmement cordial et
chaleureux qui nous a été fait nous y
voyons le signe que les relation
amicales entre la Chine et la France
iront se développant beaucoup plus
qu'elle nont pu le faire encore même
dans un passé récent et je puis affirmer
en leur nom c'est la seule fois où
j'oserai parler au nom des dirigeants
chinois que c'est bien aussi leur
intention
je vous remercie Mesdames et
Messieurs Je